كتيبه اوكرانيه تنضم للجيش الروسي اي يعقل
هذا موسكو تعلن عن ضربه كبيره كبدت القوات
الاوكرانيه خسائر فادحه الاتحاد الاوروبي
يقر بفشل جديد لمساعده اوكرانيا ويوجه
بوصلته نحو روسيا الغرب لا يجرؤون على
الاقرار
[موسيقى]
باستحالة برا وبحرا وجوا ونتنياهو يتحفظ
والمقاومه تعلن ساعه الصفر تركيا لا
يمكننا ان نبقى صامتين امام هذا الظلم
ضربه اخرى تطال الاراضي المصريه وتلا ابيب
توضح بينما اعلنت اسرائيل التصدي لهجمات
من البحر الاحمر قطر تحرز تقدما كبيرا في
ملف الاسرى ومكون يدعو الى اطلاق تحالف
انساني دعما لغزه هجوم روسي مدمر فاجاه
ودون سابق انذار استعرت الحرب في اوكرانيا
المعارك طاحنه ونيران القذائف تاكل الاخضر
واليابس لتعلن الدفاع الروسي عن ضربه
كبيره كبدت القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر فادحه
بالمعدات والافراد حيث اعلنت الوزاره
الروسيه تكبيد الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من
5585 بين قتيل وجريح واسقاط 208 مسيرات
واعتراض عشرات الصواريخ الغربيه خلال
اسبوع واسقاط 31 مقاتله اوكرانيه منذ مطلع
اكتوبر والعهده على المصدر في الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه في غضون ذلك دخلت
كتيبه من المتطوعين تحمل اسم بوجدان خملين
سكي وتم تشكيلها من افراد عسكريين سابقين
في القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه دخلت الخدمه
ضمن القوات التكتيكيه العمليات الروسيه وق
قال قائد الكتيبه اندري تشيشك في تصريح
صحفي ان افراد هذه الكتيبه سيذهبون الى خط
المواجهه بعد اداء القسم من جهه اخرى فشلت
قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي في الاتفاق على
برنامج مساعده لاوكرانيا فقررت استخدام
عائدات الاصول السياديه الروسيه المجمده
لدعم كيف ليعلن رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارل
ميشيل ان الزعماء اتفقوا على استخدام جزء
من الاصول الروسيه المجمده وفي المقام
الاول عائداتها لدعم اوكرانيا بحسب وكاله
سبوتنيك العالميه بينما اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ان
واشنطن خصصت حزمه مساعدات عسكريه لكييف
بقيمه 150 مليون دولار لياتي الدور على
رئيس وزراء هنجاريا فيكتور اوربن الذي اكد
ان ساسه الغرب لا يجرؤون على الاقرار
[موسيقى]
باستحالة الغربي جاء بلسان رئيس وزراء
لوكسمبورج زافي بيتل الذي قال انه لا
ينبغي للاتحاد الاوروبي ان يتقيد بمواقف
رئيس الوزراء الهنغاري فيكتور اوربن ويصبح
ارينه لقراره بودابيست وشبه بيتيل منع
اوربن تخصيص الاتحاد الاوروبي مزيدا من
الاموال لدعم اوكرانيا بانه اشاره بالاصبع
الوسطى البذيئه في وجه
كيف الضغط على
الزناد ساعه الصفر اقتربت كما لم تكن من
قبل ولربما انها قد بدات من يدري فلا احد
يجرؤ على ان يصرح بها حتى هذه اللحظه نعم
يا ساده عن الاجتياح البري الاسرائيلي
لغزه نتحدث وبينما كان المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي دانيل غاري قد اعلن ان القوات
البريه وسعت نشاطها البري بالتزامن مع
الضربات الجويه المكثفه التي تستهدف
القطاع هذا وكانت بعض المصادر كشفت لصحيفه
نيويورك تايم ان القياده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وضعت اللمسات الاخيره على خطه
اجتياح غزه لكن رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو رفض التوقيع عليها مضيفه ان تاجيل
الغزو يهدف جزئيا الى منح المفوضين مزيدا
من الوقت لمحاوله تامين اطلاق سراح اكثر
من 200 اسير احتجزتهم المقاومه بشان الاسر
كشف مصدر لشبكه سي ان ان التلفزيونيه ان
المفاوضات التي تقودها قطر في سبيل لاطلاق
سراح اسرى الاسرائيليين عند المقاومه في
قطاع غزه تحقق تقدما كبيرا وان هناك
انفراجات فيما قال نائب رئيس المجلس
السياسي للمقاومه ابو مرزوق الذي يزور
موسكو لوكاله ريانو فوستي نحن في المقاومه
مستعدون لاطلاق سراح جميع المدنيين الاسرى
ولكننا قلنا بوضوح ان الظروف على الارض لا
تسمح بذلك لان القصف المكثف على قطاع غزه
لا يسمح يخرج المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي في خي درعي ويعلن ان قوات مشا
ومدرعات وهندسه تابعه للفرقه 36 وبمرافقة
[موسيقى]
مشيرا الى ان عناصر الجيش الاسرائيلي
غادرت القطاع دون وقوع خسائر وفق تعبيره
هناك طلبت المقاومه في بيان الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه والمجتمع الدولي بتحمل
المسؤوليه والتحرك الفوري لوقف الجرائم
ومسلسل المجازر بحق شعب فلسطين وفق بيان
المقاومه من جهته كان رئيس اركان جيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي هيرتس هاليفي قد قال ان
الجيش اعد خطه عاليه الجوده لهجوم من بري
على قطاع غزه لكن صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
نقلا عن سبعه ضباط كبار وثلاثه مسؤولين
ذكرت بان القاده السياسيين والعسكريين
الاسرائيليين لم يقرروا بعد كيف ومتى او
ما اذا كانوا سينفذون عمليه بريه في قطاع
غزه هنا خرج وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن
الصفدي مصرحا ان اسرائيل بدات حربا بريه
على غزه وان النتيجه ستكون كارثه انسانيه
ذات ابعاد لسنوات قادمه فيما افادت قناه
الجزيره بان الجيش الاسرائيلي قال ان
طائراته تشن هجمات مكثفه وغير مسبوقه على
كافه ارجاء قطاع غزه مؤكده ان غزه تشهد
بالفعل القصف الاعنف برا وبحرا وجوا منذ
بدايه الحرب وردا على هذا القصف غير
المسبوق اطلقت فصائل المقاومه دفوعه
صاروخيه من غزه صوب المستوطنات والمدن
الاسرائيليه ليصرح وزير الخارجيه التركي
هك في بقوله ان اسرائيل تنتهك القانون
الدولي مضيفا لا يمكننا ان نبقى صامتين في
وجه هذا الظلم فيما اكد مكتب مفوض حقوق
الانسان لدى الامم المتحده ان العقاب
الجماعي الذي تفرضه اسرائيل على سكان غزه
من خلال الحصار وقصف المناطق المكتظه
بالسكان يعد جريمه حرب ما يجري في غزه تصل
اثاره وتبعاته للاراضي المصريه وبعد ان
اعلنت القوات المسلحه المصريه في بيان قطه
طائره بدون طيار مجهوله في طابه بجوار احد
المباني بجانب مستشفى طابه واضاف البيان
ان الحادثه اسفر عن اصابات طفيفه لسته
اشخاص تم خروجهم من المستشفى بعد تلقي
الاسعافات اللازمه ليرد الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان الموضوع قيد التحقيق فيما اعلن مصدران
امنيين مصريان بحديث لرويترز ان قذيفه
سقطت في مدينه ويبع بالقرب من محطه كهرباء
ويبع على الساحل الغربي لخليج العق ق
بالبحر الاحمر وان السلطات المختصه تحقق
في الحادث ليعود الجيش الاسرائيلي ويعلن
ان المقذوف الذي سقط في مصر مرتبط فيما
يبدو بتهديد جوي فوق البحر الاحمر دون ان
يخوض في تفاصيل او تقديم اي ايضاحه واضاف
المتحدث العسكري باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
افيخاي ادرعي رصدنا تهديدا جويا في منطقه
البحر الاحمر واستدعي طائرات حربيه
للتعامل معه هنا نعود الى الميدان
الفلسطيني حيث اعلنت وزار الصحه في قطاع
غزه ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا القصف الاسرائيلي
على القطاع منذ السابع من الشهر الجاري
الى اكثر من
7300 شخص وبعد هذه الخسائر اكد الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون انه يتطلع الى
بناء تحالف انساني بشان غزه في محادثات مع
قبرص واليونان وطالب الرئيس الفرنسي
بهدنيه انسانيه في غزه مشيرا الى انها
ستكون مفيده لتعلن المقاومه عن قصف مجمع
شل منير اسحاق في غلاف غزه برشقه صاروخيه
كما طال القصف الزوارق الحربيه المتمركزه
قباله مدينه غزه حسب ما اعلنت المقاومه في
[موسيقى]
بيانها